now let me show you
why Jesus said in the new creation you
must be born of water and spirit because
the old creation was made of water by
the spirit
here watch
here see the Bible is miraculous and if
you believe the Bible is consistent it
all makes sense look in the new creation
to be born a new you must be born of
water and spirit
why because the old creation the Earth
was made of water by the spirit you see
so he's going to
restore the
creation by the very elements and entity
that made the creation in the first
place the Holy Spirit using the Waters
of the earth to make the Earth alive
teeming with life here in the beginning
God created heavens and the Earth and
the Earth was formless and void and
darkness was over the surface of deep
and the spirit of God was hovering over
the surface of the waters it is from
these Waters that the Holy Spirit made
the Earth habitable teaming with
life so why would you be
shocked that now that God wants to
restore that Earth restore those humans
from the dust he's going to use the same
elements and entity water and
spirit you with me there
you got it
there in fact here let me go further
when Adam Was Made Alive look how he's
made Let's see if you're going to see
this here you
go watch here Genesis 24
to7 Jesus answered truly truly I say to
you unless one is born of water in the
spirit he cannot enter the kingdom
heaven now watch what about Adam who was
made in image of God by what by whom and
what here you go Genesis 2 Verses 4 to
7 are you getting this or you're going
to sleep so the early church was right
water baptism in the spirit it's the
Reformed Baptist and the Baptist and a
Baptist they're wrong they came too late
one universal teaching of the church
that you'll find everywhere confirmed as
far back as you can go Bible 2 Century
third Century 4th Century fifth century
Orthodox and Heretics even Martin Luther
up until the 1500s water baptism is used
by the Holy Spirit to make you alive and
unite you to
Christ this rejection of water
baptism as the means by which the Holy
Spirit Works to restore you and make you
alive it's recent in history don't take
my word for it go study
history because look how God made the
first man Genesis
24-7 okay look look how you made them
right these are the generations of the
heavens and the earth when they were
created in the day that Yahweh God made
the Earth and Heaven now no shrub of the
field was yet in the earth now watch and
no plant of the field had yet grown for
Yahweh God had not caused it to rain
upon the Earth okay and there was no man
to cultivate the ground if you've been
watching my series on Jesus and Genesis
and how Genesis is a picture of Christ
and the Virgin birth and all you should
know this already notice
that the ground was virgin ground it was
virgin
soil virgin
ground virgin
soil virgin soil no man had plantet
seeds virgin
Earth Adam was made from Virgin soil
like the last Adam was made from Virgin
soil the holy virgin womb of Mary but
wait look at the water but a stream
would rise from the earth and water the
whole surface of the ground so why would
you be shocked that if the first man was
made from dust that had been watered and
he was made Alive by the Breath of Life
which means the Holy Spirit sent forth
to make him alive that's what the Breath
of Life is then why would you be shocked
that in the
recreation and the
Regeneration God will use the the same
element water and the same entity the
Holy Spirit to renew
you why would you be
shocked God is
consistent why would you be
shocked because the breath of life that
is a metaphor for God sending forth the
spirit because God is not a physical
being he doesn't physically breathe but
when he sends the spirit it's the spirit
that gives you breath animates you
produces a soul in you that he sustains
because without breath you can't live
then Yahweh God formed man of dust from
the ground breathe into his nostril
breath light and so the Man became a
living me a living
Soul yes that was the other example I
was going to use you're a genius God
bless
you
exactly right this is why I changed my
position and I saw I was wrong
because these were man-made Traditions
unknown among the Christians for over
1500 years none of them denied water
baptismal generation that the Holy
Spirit uses water to regenerate you and
make you alive none of them even
Heretics believe
that and here comes anabaptist and the
Baptists denying it Johnny come
lately sinking in thank you master of
voice
sinking in you see like the initial
creation was made of water which the
Holy Spirit used and like the first
man was made of ground that was a virgin
ground that had been watered and Made
Alive by the Breath of Life the Holy
Spirit your Recreation renewal is used
is made through the use of water and by
the spirit
one way just go to my YouTube channel
and put in Jesus and garden here let me
show you just use the search on
YouTube one's the last time Catholic and
Orthodox one's the last time Catholic
and Orthodox your churches taught you
the miraculous Supernatural consistency
and connection between spirit and water
to strengthen that the church has always
been right it's these guys with their
modern heresies that are wrong here
Jesus Garden you just put two words
Jesus garden and what comes up Jesus in
the Garden of Eden Jesus in The Garden
of even part two Jesus in the garden
even part three Jesus in the garden even
part five part
six Jesus in the garden final touches
make these videos go viral folks you'll
be blown away you'll be in awe and
you're going to know the Bible's
miraculous and Supernatural
and tell them I love you Indonesian
Christians I'm your servant Lord Jesus
fill you and protect you and preserve
you yeah I know it's very easy so why
don't I send you there to find it for us
and report
back all
right
okay do you now understand what it
means yeah someone asked me about the
blind man so let me bring it up all
right right how did God how did Jesus
restore the eyes of the blind man watch
the
connection John 9 verses 1 to 7 let's
read from well yeah let me read 1 s all
right here you go watch
here notice again how he does it Jes as
he passed by he saw a man blind from
birth John
91:7 and his disciples asked him saying
rabi Robie who sinned this man or his
parents that he would be born blind
Jesus answered neither this man nor his
parents sinned but this was so that the
works of God may be man manifested in
him we must work the works of him who
sent me as long as as it is day night is
coming when no one can work now watch
the connection Genesis 2 while I am in
the world I am the light of the world
when he said this he spat on the ground
he moistened the ground he made it wet
that's Genesis too the the ground was
made moist and wet by
water made clay of saliva and the human
body with eyeballs and ears and teeth
was made from that ground from the dust
that had been moistened by water what is
saliva water right it's spit right and
air made clay of saliva rub the clay in
his eyes and some go wash in the pool of
Salam soam means
scent and what did the spirit use to
create the earth water so he went away
washed and came back
seeing you see it do you see the
connection with Genesis 24-7
you see the
connection yep the water from the
Creator this is Jesus the God man his
saliva would be
his right it would be air and the water
from his mouth the saliva of the
lifegiving
Creator you see
it yeah Dr Rock Focus please don't
change it into denominations and I want
to send you guys out of
here you saw it or
no are you seeing the connection with
Genesis 2 4-7 how did God make Adam from
the dust that had been
moist with water and he shaped his body
that means your eyeballs came from the
dust your ears came from the dust
because it was made from dust by
yahweh's hand yahweh's hand right for
here's the hands of Yahweh Jesus Is God
In the Flesh who has physical hands and
with those same physical hands he took
from the
ground spat on it and placed it on his
eyes and then sent them into the water
so he came back
seeing which now points to water
baptismal regeneration cuz you go in the
water F blind deaf dumb and dead
and you come out alive hearing and
seeing see the
connection is it making sense
now the connection
now but this is the
Bible so the ancient churches were
always right the early Christians right
and this is what they believe for 1500
years all the way even Martin Luther
believed it
anglicans believe it Church of Christ
believes it episcopalians water
baptismal
regeneration but what do you understand
now what it means to be a child of God a
Son of God a daughter of
God you understand what that means now
it took me 20 years to get to where many
of you have always been you who were
raised Catholics Orthodox you've been
spoiled and you take your faith for
granted I had to study and WR and
agonize and debate and fight until
finally I realized you guys were right
you've had the truth but you've taken
advantage of it because you didn't learn
your faith you didn't desire to
understand your faith right and took it
for granted
whereas it took me 20
years of debating and arguing and
agonizing and until finally said said
yeah they're right I'm
wrong and here's my article on how the
early church understood water baptism
and regeneration in john 35 let me give
it to you he just sent you the link he
just sent you the link right right there
but let me click on it so you can see
it what you've always had and by the way
go to Romeo And subscribe to his channel
he's got some great videos it took me 20
years to get to your point because my
Assyrian Church didn't catechize me
my parents didn't catechize me I was
being catechized by independent
fundamental Baptist when I was a child
and then later calvinist and I thought
water baptism was a heresy little did I
know we were the
Heretics right here's the Articles he
just gave you the link forther you
on
Rumble but I thank God for that you know
why
had it not been for these 20 years I
would not be this strong this
understanding this strengthen in this
conviction because I know their
objections and I know how to refute them
by the power of the Lord Jesus
Christ here it is relationship between
belief and water
baptism this is the article I show you
the connection that's one article but
then I'm going to show you the early
church so there it is I just sent you
the link and Romeo sent it to you in
YouTube go there boom first example
second example third example boom boom
boom right but now I'm going to give you
the other article how did the early
church the Disciples of the Apostles the
Bishops appointed by them and their
disciples s john 35 and the r of water
let me see if I link it here let me give
it to you let me show it to you the
other
one
okay here it goes this is the other one
right here here's the other one he
Romeo's been sharing it I'm going to
give it to you on right here I'm going
to give it to you
here on Rumble there it is so let me
post it
here boom early church fathers on John
35 order
baptism whenever they spoke of john 35
or water baptism
unanimously unbroken chain of su
succession from the first century on
they all taught to a tea john 35 the
water is water baptism used by the
spirit and the spirit uses water to
regenerate you and unite you to Christ
unanimous teaching of all the Christians
even the Heretics believe this that was
not a point of contention you're saying
they're all wrong and you guys got it
right 2,000 years later the audacity and
the arrogance there it
is so James White got it right Anthony
Rogers that cow that tool of s got it
right
you with me
there you with me
there so I had to go through this Agony
thank you Chris to get to where you guys
have been but you've taken advantage of
it so let's wrap wrap up the point again
because I'm going to show you that when
Jesus Son of God it means he has the
nature of God he's equal to God the
Father possesses theine nature and all
the fullness
because Son of God doesn't simply mean
God as his father it also means one who
partakes of the nature of
God we got it
now
okay so let me again show you what it
means to be a Son of God here it is
black and white theosis one more time a
Son of God a daughter of God means you
partake of the divine nature meaning God
has destined you to become morally
Incorruptible and deathless to be like
God in his immortality and to be like
God in his moral incorruptibility and to
be like God and seeing reality as it is
unfiltered unmediated seeing God
directly perceiving God directly and
seeing things as they are because you're
going to have the mind of God